it cannot go on this way when I'm
president we will even up the score and
we will tax the hell out of the wealthy
the people in this room and the
Democrats watching tonight are the last
best hope for humanity on this planet
Donald Trump from Charleston to
Baltimore to even the border is using
the tired old language of demagogues of
fear mongers of racist here with
reaction all those breaking news tonight
Senate Judiciary Committee Chair Lindsey
Graham senator first let's start with
John Solomon's breaking news report well
we've been waiting for the IG report we
hear now it's mid-august we understand
there's reasons for the delays that are
far bigger than the issue of the
violation of the Espionage Act that he's
referring coaming from prosecution for
and of course being less than candid
lack of candor but we can't have a
two-tier justice system either I
understand if the AG is looking at these
other issues first but the decline
prosecution if he believes the laws are
broken I think we really have to
reevaluate that yeah number one I want
to see the report I like John Solomon
he's a good reporter but if it's true
the Inspector General has referred the
FBI director for criminal prosecutor
that's stunning
okay we'll know in a few weeks is
stunning now if bill Barr decided not to
prosecute on disclosing the memos I
accept his judgment I've known him for
20 years and I have no desire for him to
be like Muller I want him to do what he
thinks is right by the law and not
prosecute anybody if you don't think the
case is there because somebody else got
mystery there's no reason to continue
that practice so if it's true and we'll
know pretty soon it's stunning
beyond stunning it is to me here's my
interpretation of the top M what do I
know I'm just a talk job I don't know I
kind of see bar as a as a really
thorough extraordinarily bright human
being are they two of the best picks the
president maybe would be Mike Pompeo and
Bill Bar as Attorney General just off
the device
my head and I'd say that probably bars
recognized the Phi's abuse issues that
we have talked about and if James Comey
was warned that it's unverifiable never
verified Hillary paid for it oh and by
the way still as an agenda and he signed
it anyway and we now know according to
the Grassley Graham memo the bulk of
that information was in fact the dossier
with Russian lies or as the New York
Times says was from the get-go Russian
disinformation that would prove number
one the Russians were favoring Hillary
and number two it would prove that
Attorney General bar is being a little
bit more he's playing chess and long
ball he's not playing checkers and that
he sees that they're a bigger fish to
fry down the road and he can always
revisit that issue but what do I know
I'm not only a host well I think you
know a lot about this and if Bill Barr
said they may be a case there but I
think it's out of abundance of caution I
won't bring it good that's what you
won't probably have to do yeah I mean
but the point is if you've got some
doubt about the validity of the case
just don't throw it up against the wall
and see if it's to do you want the first
case you brought in jeopardy of not
winning that would these other cases are
stronger yeah you know a lot about
prosecution even though yet been won the
worst thing you can do is overcharge
somebody it began to fall apart then it
taints the thing that really is strong
you're the lawyer I'm learning from you
I used to this for a living there's two
ways to do this though everything the
kitchen sink at the accused and hope he
pleads to something or make sure that
when you charge them it will not be
undermined is you overcharged this what
happened with Muller they tried to scare
people into writing on Trump it didn't
work they were overcharged and I hope
some of these people will have their
case revisited but the fact that that
bar is showing some prosecutorial
discretion that is evened and reasoned
is a step in the right direction
and if he does bring a charge against
Comey after doing this I'd hate to be
Comey
I think I'd hate to be
me I've tried to be a good guy and
warned James Comey I told them before
his stupid book came out that he has the
right to remain silent to take that
right seriously now I'm just gonna
advise them not only do you have their
right if I was you
super Patriot Jim Comey I just shut the
hell up because you're hurting yourself
every time you open your big fat mouth I
can't be any more blunt than that
because I'm a talk-show host and I'm not
a senator just from a from a
prosecutor's point of view you don't
want to undermine a bigger case by
throwing out some stuff that may be as
if he cuz that only hurts you down the
road so if there was an abuse of the
FISA process that if there was a
misleading of the court by the FBI
director that is a monumental crime and
I would focus on that if that's what
happened all right senator I know you'll
be getting through all of this and
bringing all these nations up and we
appreciate you being with us